so you just wrap the good players yeah
we do great show do you have anything
thank you
all of them are all the moments we just
create memories I mean I get to work
with like the best people yeah TV legend
Ted Danson Super Mom Kristen Bell well
like most of my memories are with Ted
and like he's just you know the biggest
goofball like especially when the the
Sun comes down and the Sun and the
moon's out like and there's a lot of
sugar that goes around on so I was like
this he become a werewolf this moment
where me and my other you had him on
this shows a will Harper we were just
having a conversation with him with Ted
and we're just fooling around and then I
was talking to will and then I hear a
noise over in Ted's corner and then like
a gurgling breathing noise oh and and
then I just look at Ted and you know
like are you okay and then we go about
our business and then I hear it again
and then I look closer and then there's
like something like red and gooey up
Ted's nose and then he takes a breath
what and then he goes and then he snorts
out this swedish fish
gummy yeah this is a 70 year old man
like why did you do that I don't care if
just I will not stop talking until you
subscribe to my youtube channel that's
right and I could talk a lot seriously
not gonna stop yep still here not going
anywhere I see you don't walk away from
this